[Musique]
à l'origine c'était un projet de
recherche d'une thèse de doctorat que
j'ai effectués donc c'est au cours de
cette thèse qu'on a développé le projet
jirau lift différents démonstrateurs
prototypes
c'est pendant cette période qu'a germé
l'idée entreprenariale et c'est à la
sortir ça continuera pourquoi pas la
mener jusqu'à la commercialisation c'est
comme ça que j'ai reçue était devenue
une start up
las vegas est arrivé un peu rapidement
un peu de manière un peu surprenante
c'est à dire que j'ai juste candidate
est un concours organisé par la cci
versailles yvelines qui permettait aux
deux lauréats d'avoir le voyage et les
billets pour rentrer au salon un du cms
de las vegas et au final je me suis
rangé remporté avec une autre énergie
skweres le concours on a commencé à
chercher des partenaires qui allait et
au final angie avait un stand et nous a
proposé d'exposer notre jolie au final
ça s'est très très bien passé énormément
de visibilité de contact avec des grands
comptes des industriels des
investisseurs s'est intéressée ici pour
soi pour l'industrie lisation pour la
commercialisation et ses énergies
scolaire c'est l'entreprise que l'on a
créé lorsqu'on était étudiant
entrepreneur de l'université paris
saclay et donc c'était avec le pôle
entrepreneuriat de l'université paris
saclay et donc c'est là-bas que le
projet n'est la société énergie skweres
notre coeur de métier s'est développé
une nouvelle technologie de charge pour
des appareils électroniques donc pour
des smartphones des tablettes
donc l'idée c'est d'avoir des surfaces
sur lesquelles on peut poser tous ces
appareils est chargé tous ces appareils
en même temps et dans le développement
dans notre société on a lancé un premier
produit qui est une surface de recharge
pour smartphones et tablettes
et maintenant on travaille sur des
produits d'intégration qui permettent
d'intégrer notre technologie dont des
tables par exemple pour charger son
ordinateur portable ou directement dans
des appareils électroniques
le servette est le plus grand salon
d'électronique au monde et nous on
voulait y présenter nos produits parce
que la plupart de nos clients sont là
bas puis on a eu un stand là bas avec
business france dans la délégation
française qui faisait partie de cette
édition du csp retour du cvs ont été
très bon pour nous on a rencontré une
soixantaine de clients qui
potentiellement pourrait être intéressée
pour acheter nos produits ou notre
technologie est donc en ce moment mais
en train de relancer toutes ces
personnes ça peut des fabricants
d'appareils électroniques par exemple
qui ont besoin de notre technologie dans
leurs produits ou des personnes qui ont
tout un tas d'appareils à recharger des
smartphones ou des tablettes par exemple
[Musique]